you won't like me when I'm angry because
now I have a giant black friend who will
take you down the aging black this is
Erin Alexander right here
my great friend awesome poet guys follow
him on Instagram as soon as you can
Erin and I have no chair for a while now
and it's long overdue that he's on the
channel huge Marvel and DC fans usually
we talk about and then life I've heard
of the channel new rock stars like the
drink right oh boy Disney Plus returned
confirmed Red Hulk theory I'm not too
familiar Red Hulk you know some stuff
about Red Hulk he's general Ross an old
man who has a grudge against the old
hawkster is a mustache when he's man but
not when he's red nobody is all hulking
out which doesn't make really a lot of
sense but I'll go with it we go with it
I'm excited to see what it does in the
show it's about damn time
Marvel watching this video right gray oh
boy
welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in the Hulk may have a future in
the MCU after all with new details
coming out about the she-hulk series on
Disney plan for once these details
weren't spoiled by Mark Ruffalo saying
too much in the interview wait till you
see this next one everybody talks funny
no one believes I know that's amazing
but beyond these casting rumors the
precise way she hoped will connect to
the Hulk as we know him currently in the
MCU and that answer slams the door wide
open for where they could go with the
Holt franchise in the future what
warning in case you consider widely
available news spoiler yeah we just
learned working title for the she-hulk
series is Libra a reference to the
astrological sign depicted with scales
as a reference to Jennifer Walters
career as an attorney
the caste noticed the show's ECB's
she-hulk actress reads she-hulk is a
lawyer and cousin of Bruce Banner whose
emergency blood transfusion from Bruce
empowers her with hulk-like abilities yo
ya hear that the original origin story
for Jennifer Walters who in the comics
is a cousin to Bruce Banner her legal
involvement with a criminal case leads
to her getting shot and losing a lot of
blood but Bruce gives her a transfusion
and his gamma-irradiated blood
transforms her into the shields like a
vampire but stays in she-hulk form
fighting alongside the Avengers and
other Marvel heroes the fact that Marvel
Studios is sticking with this Hulk blood
origin as the explanation for Jenn's
powers is significant because an
Avengers endgame Smart Hulk explained
his fusion with some vague Mushmouth in
about spending 18 months in the gamma
lab I put the brains and the big and
it's never really been consistent
whether Banner does or doesn't retain
memories when he's in Hulk form first to
get angrier and angrier never lose a
fight yet Thanos knocked him out cold
because a thunderclap is powerful enough
to extinguish jet fuel
fire but not blow the skin off Betty
Ross's bones my father comes to that's
at Norton Hulk film that many of us for
hit was even part of MCU bannard cut
himself and bleeds and Warner forgot I
was in a factory bottles and later make
people ill with a big gamma suit
assistant was Stanley digestion of his
blood may have been bad it sounds like
transfusions into the bloodstream which
will be okay more than okay this would
actually be consistent with the planet
whole comic storyline in which Hulk's
blood has healing powers which he uses
on the people it's a car life
considering we have seen Planet Hulk
adapted for Thor Ragnarok
it's the storyline that follows Planet
Hulk that I think could inspire what we
will see next from Hulk in the MCU let's
hear it he do tell in she-hulk but
before I can forget everything you know
about mobile games folks crystallization
in advance on Android bosses collect
exclusive heroes and play with your
friends from around the world with
products I think we really enough by
this
use my link below to download crystal on
yourself crystal born is a featured top
new game on the Apple App Store my
favorite character lately has been this
big shirtless dude aliens maximum magic
swords and insane special powers all of
that Maximoff just straight-up gets in
people's face isn't I pre-cut some after
playing the game for a while I've been
able to level him up and boost his armor
so now those uppercuts are extra nasty
max baucus news the other epic level
characters I've been able to summon do
battle on my behalf to win campaigns and
in the player vs. player mode right keep
tweaking rewards here's my link below to
download it was stillborn yourself and
thanks again so if she like is going to
keep Bruce Banner in the MCU as the
donor of e gamma-irradiated blood that
gives her her powers this makes Hulk
blood a lot more valuable to this
because anyone could be Hulka fide with
a similar transfusion that would
correspond neatly to the storyline that
follows Planet Hulk world
Warhawks nutso crossover event that
features Hulk a fight versions of
several Marvel heroes cats spider-man
Wolverine Thor dead
Red Hulk is a player he's revealed to be
Thunderbolt Ross Rossi you must actually
see mustaches to transform himself into
Red Hulk in order to fight Hulk as Red
Hulk it's angrier he emits heat making
himself vulnerable to overheating Red
Hulk in general is Wow more aggressive
he killed domination of Troyes the
Helicarrier he causes an earthquake in
San Francisco and while all this sounds
crazy the current MCU is becoming
increasingly set up for a Red Hulk world
war Hulk's event Thunderbolt Ross is
still around back in Civil War infinity
Wars Scottsdale in game and now in Black
Widow now I have regulated that Ross
could be ignored and the Thunderbolts
plots in the Falcon Avenger but perhaps
that could end according to series and
set photos for the fact in the Winter
Soldier names in construction signs
rebuilding the world a pin the snap now
Simpson could be a nod to doc Samson
plays a pretty big role in the world war
hulk 7th and the character simpson was
played by Ty Burrell in this fulfills
and before we say the Marvel movies will
never condemn these cult titles because
the film rights are owned by a separate
rival studio Universal cool those Jets
now sure in the past
rights by rival Studios extended to
characters related to the main title so
like for example Sony owns the rights to
spider-man which also by extension gives
them rights to spider-man related
characters like venom and Morbius and
when Fox was a separate studio it owned
the rights to the x-men and Fantastic
Four but also by extension had Deadpool
and two mutants and ego the Libyan
planet who Fantastic Four villain but
through a special deal of IP swapping
Marvel was able to get special
permission to use them in the guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 but with all this in
mind the fact that Disney Plus is doing
HG Hulk series signals that universals
ownership of the Hulk world isn't as
ironclad as we thought now maybe the
legal is wording is looser when a great
series as opposed to theatrical releases
and legal eagle Jen Walters found a
loophole or maybe since she Hulk was
once a member of the Fantastic Four box
could have had a stronger claim to the
character now Disney
remember the recent rumor has it that
Marvel execs aren't too worried about
the Hulk rights anymore and Mark Ruffalo
has been meeting with Feige about future
solo films really with rebel is there's
no mo cocky in the trunk or she whole
bit is now closer to streaming down all
the MCS beans confident with your
thoughts on this and for our deeper
unfiltered Marvel theories this coin our
official discord server by becoming a
patron of new rock stars you get a
Twitter a TA vos follow the new rock
stars and subscribe to new rock stars
here and you too / breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye awesome a lot of information it was
I felt very educated thanks guy alright
subscribe see you guys once again great
job to the team a new rock stars for
putting this video together brought some
interesting theories here things that I
definitely do not think about so the
main focus of this video was involving
like the world war Hulk's Red Hulk now I
didn't take it as the world war Hulk's
thing or anything with Red Hulk
necessarily would be a focus and the
she-hulk show itself but maybe that the
she-hulk series might be a way to start
setting up or introducing this element
as honestly if you're gonna do a
she-hulk series I feel you got to put
all your focus on shield maybe having
like sprinkles Easter eggs nuggets that
hint at the potential to doing something
like this would be pretty cool but if
they start putting that in the show
suddenly it's more of a Hulk show than
it is a central focus of she-hulk you
know what I mean yeah and I felt like it
would take away things that make her
cool on her own character because focus
on her being a lawyer and then she's
also one of the few careful characters
outside of Deadpool and break the fourth
wall which would be with something to be
really interesting give her her own
villains if you are gonna do sort of a
Red Hulk situation do she Red Hulk which
is spoilers people don't know it's his
daughter it's Betty which I don't know
if the rule is it yeah it does Dodd Oh
Dave yeah so that'd be cool but I feel
like you got to set up Red Hawk before
you can introduce she Red Hulk you
should come on this channel more love
this dude as a host I feel like he's a
really educational very well-spoken
guide to deliver the information every
boss that is a great point though that
they he did bring up about how general
Ross has been coming back a lot more
into the fold than the MCU with Civil
War I remember the excitement of the him
coming back was hey they're actually
acknowledging that Hulk film with Edward
Norton yeah yeah like we haven't just
forgot about it ya know a film was
definitely still candid no cuz there was
not we were like yeah how canon is that
movie yeah yeah then the fact that he
was at our screen role that he is in
Black Widow maybe Black Widow will use
an opportunity to kind of put that back
in the in the MCU zeitgeist
um yeah we might be leading down that
road someday I like that are sticking
with getting the blood transfusion from
her cousin Bruce Banner I have said this
before and I'm gonna repeat it here
again I really hope that it seems like
it's inevitable that it will probably
get a Mark Ruffalo cameo in this year oh
I thought like it's more than like 100
percent he's probably you know how those
Netflix Marvel shows they would
sometimes show you the origin of the
character like the third or fourth
episode I would kind of want that for
this one because I think if you do that
thing where you have Mark Ruffalo in the
very first episode
it might make you be like I want Mark
Ruffalo in it throughout right where as
opposed to putting him in an episode a
little bit later on even if it is the
first season if you put him in a little
bit later on like the third or fourth
episode or something he'll be like a
nice surprise it'll be fun but it won't
be like oh I wish he was like a main
character here it's just something
expectation yeah and you're like how the
show would be better if he was here you
know and so I feel like that would be
the best bet and the other thing too is
it's like when you look at the comic
panels for even likes professor Hulk
smart hope whatever the hell you want to
call him or any version of Hulk vs.
she-hulk she hoax still looks like a
sexy woman she stays at Hulk forum
because despite the fact that she is in
Hulk form for herself she's still pretty
friggin hot all thanks yeah
with that in mind one thing that I think
the MCU doesn't do often enough that
I know it's expensive it's more
time-consuming and everything I would be
pretty happy if they decided to make
whoever they cast as she-hulk
in make up form I think they could kind
of get away with doing that it would be
very time-consuming I highly doubt they
would do it this is just wishful
thinking
but I think too for watching a series it
would probably move them to do it and
maybe in a way hearkened back how they
did the Incredible Hulk with Lou
Ferrigno then again with it I mean you
have to get a different actress to play
right old version but then she's
primarily in shiho version a lot of the
times not sure how they would do unless
they like add on muscles - yeah version
of she-hulk you know I highly doubt they
do it into something that I would wish
for yeah I feel like Marvel typically
they don't necessarily go for the
biggest star possible but they go for
talent and charisma and I feel like
granted that could go unknown but as far
as people in the zeitgeist that we are
familiar with that are these
larger-than-life character actresses
they are typically on the smaller side
so I imagine they would go for something
that's more motion capture you know
action that's gonna be really expensive
to do
I mean hey they got that Marvel money
and they can billion-dollar hit after
billion-dollar hit so I don't think it's
gonna be a pause a problem for them but
also to make it blend with the other
characters yeah it's like you can't have
Hulk in a makeup so true if like Hulk
makes an appearance it might look a
little jarring to have like a makeup
she-hulk and then a CGI oh yeah you know
sharing this great day probably wouldn't
blend well something I didn't think
they're gonna do is probably sort of
streamline and update her costume
because with characters like captured
you'll be wearing a bikini they're
probably give her like pants ooh but
still keep the color scheme of like her
did a traditional costume it's what
ruined birds of prey that's why birds of
prey did not do well the box office
covered up Harley Quinn
everyone to see more sexy I can't sit
through this I mean I gotta go to close
I'm not sweating it out and I like the
idea of getting Red Hulk down the road
especially if they are gonna be able to
successfully pull off these solo Hulk
films I think getting World War Hulk
getting Red Hulk involved I think it'd
be an awesome build-up you know how like
in the original Sam Raimi spider-man
trilogy we had dr. Connors it was like
ooh one day we'll get the lizard and we
never got that yeah I think they can
fulfill that with general Ross like oh
we've had general Ross here the whole
time spot but general Ross the whole
time oh now he's like a major villain
that would be really excellent that
would be different for the MCU
speaking of them bringing back
characters from the original original
2008 Hulk film I think it'd be
interesting if they brought back doc
Samson or ty what's the name Tye
Sheridan
that's the who played Cyclops as it was
not ready player one yes that Ty Ty
Woody's doc Samson I think they're
really interesting and they brought him
there but I think they're gonna recast
honestly they should bring back everyone
but Edward or pull a total aunt viv look
at the camera guys it's a show Fresh
Prince of bel-air see I I know shows
that don't star white people see more
than friends he has a black friend he is
too
tyro Magnus and me and aqus and Paris on
that guy a subscribe to new rock stars
or an amazing channel link in the
description box when I'm linking the
pink calm and make sure to subscribe to
the real rejects as well click our
notification bell follow Aaron Alexander
on Instagram and you stay classy San
Diego